foreign
[Music]
hi everyone thank you for coming to my
talk on how to build Next Generation
data pipelines with containers
my name is Carolina
and I'm a product manager at Google
Cloud I work on cloud run
so we've all heard that data is at the
heart of modern applications
it's used to make business decisions
improve products and services
and create new opportunities and this is
becoming even more true with the rise of
AI driven applications
because your AI powered applications
only ever going to be as good
as your data
So today we're going to talk about three
types of data processing
on-demand data processing
oh well look at that
slides that's not my slides
but those are my slides
thank you
okay ah there we go
let's go a little bit backwards
so we're going to talk about three types
of data processing
on-demand data processing batch data
processing and streaming data processing
and I'll show you how to build these
pipelines using containers as our basic
building block
containers of course are the
standardized immutable basic building
block of modern Cloud native
applications
and there are the next Evolution step in
the move from on-prem Hardware
to Virtual machines to now containerized
applications each step progressively
abstracting away more and more
infrastructure
and containers give you two really
important things
the first is flexibility
flexibility allows you to use any
framework and any language so that
you're not limited to what a particular
data processing platform offers but can
choose what's right for your application
and your organization
and portability lets you move your
container to the best compute platform
for your use case
and what I mean by that this slide shows
different ways that you can run a
container in Google Cloud
say you start with Cloud run but then
you find that you actually need access
to local disk no problem you can take
that same container without rebuilding
it and move it to GK autopilot
now you can access local disk and you
still have a pretty fully managed data
platform
container platform or perhaps you decide
that you need to use a processing
algorithm that requires fast internode
communication
for that Google batch is a great choice
so you take your container and you move
it to Google batch which is our our
product that supports high performance
compute use cases and you can keep
moving to the right
accessing more and more layers of
infrastructure but of course at the cost
of having to do more and more
operational work
so I'm going to State a principal I
think you should always start with the
product at the highest level of
abstraction that works for you and only
move towards less managed products as
needed
so for container platforms that highest
level of abstraction product is cloud
run and I'm going to talk about Cloud
run quite a bit in this talk so I'm
going to give a really brief overview
Cloud run is our fully managed container
platform
it's a great fit for a variety of
serving and data processing workloads
and we designed Cloud run with
Simplicity and Automation in mind
to get you as fast as possible from
prototype to production application
and because Cloud run runs containers
you get that flexibility and portability
that we talked about
so without further Ado let's talk about
on-demand data processing
so on-demand data processing is when you
have some data and you need to process
it on an ad hoc basis
perhaps you need to generate a business
report
or perhaps you need to migrate your
database to a new schema
and you probably don't want to run this
on your laptop in fact hopefully you
don't actually have production access
from your laptop
so you also don't really want to have to
create a VM and install software and all
of that you want an easy way to run your
script in the cloud
and so Cloud run jobs are a really good
fit for this
this is how you run us
in quadrant bash screen Cloud run
assuming you've already built your
container
um using either Docker build or Cloud
build
you run gcloud run jobs deploy you give
it a name
and you tell it where your image is
this is going to create a cloud run job
which is essentially an object that
encapsulates your container your code as
well as all the configuration around it
and then you run that job with a really
simple command
Cloud run jobs just like Cloud run are
fully managed
you deploy your container and Cloud run
takes care of scheduling your instances
and stopping all instances when they're
done so that you only pay when the job
is actually running
and Cloud run jobs work with all common
data storage solutions so that no matter
where your data is
as long as it's stored either in a
Google Cloud
managed storage solution or is
accessible from your VPC Network you'll
be able to process it and access it
using Cloud run jobs
foreign
So eventually you might end up with jobs
that are pretty large you need to
process a large amount of data
and sometimes you're in a situation
where you want to get to results fast
perhaps because that business report is
due you know in an hour
um one way you can make this you can
make your jobs run faster is by
parallelizing them
what this means is you break up your job
into multiple tasks
where each task is a running copy of
your container
and each task is aware of its task index
as well as the total number of tasks
and you can use that information to
structure your code in a way that each
task does a simple computation to figure
out is this input for me or is this for
one of the other tasks so each task
process is only a subset of the input
and so I'm going to show you what this
looks like in Cloud run jobs
so I'm going to create a job
my job's being created
I pick a container and I tell it how
many tasks
so we're going to run this with a
hundred tasks so nothing's running yet
and now I click execute
and let's take a look at it so what
cloud runs doing right now is it's
scheduling 100 instances of this
container
and starting them and this is a
real-time video so we're all going to
sit here for a little bit and watch this
spin because I wanted to show you how
fast this is
just like that we have started and
finished running 100 containers
so of course these contain this the
sample container doesn't do a whole lot
but still running this many containers
this quickly
is I think pretty unique
now you might say Carolina that's all
nice
but I don't really want to change my
code to tell each task which input to
process and deal with parallelizing my
jobs I just want to take my existing
long-running job
and run it in Cloud run without having
to do anything extra
and if that's the case I have good news
for you because Cloud run jobs now
support up to 24 hour timeouts so that
means that each task of your job can run
for up to 24 hours so as long as your
job takes less than 24 hours you can
just deploy to Cloud run and it will
rent a completion
so that was on demand data processing
let's talk about batch data processing
now which is much the same you have a
bunch of data and you want to process it
all at once but the big difference tends
to be that you want to orchestrate it in
some way rather than like click execute
um here are some common times when you
need to do batch data processing for
example if you are maintaining even a
very simple web app
you'll find that you need to um
do have various pipelines that handle
deletions so that if one of your users
deleted their data
you want to make sure you've actually
deleted from everywhere in your system
you want to probably periodically audit
your Access Control list so that the
right people have the access to the
right information
you might have some database management
scripts going on as well as business
analytics scripts because you want to
make sure that your logs and user data
is exported to a format where you can
actually use it to make business
decisions
and so
one thing we did this one thing we did
in Claude Ryan jobs to facilitate
batch pipelines is that we clearly
separated management of jobs from
running of jobs
so uh you saw earlier that you create a
job and then you run a job this lets you
manage your jobs with an infrastructure
as code approach for example using
terraform or config connector
that's how you would manage you know
updating the container for example
and then you can you can manage the
actual running you can treat the running
of jobs as a data plane operation
and so you can easily run your jobs
programmatically using either an API
call or a client Library
or orchestration products like Google's
Cloud scheduler or workflows so let's
take a look at that
so I want to show you how you would set
up a scheduled job in Cloud run jobs
so we go to the cloud run jobs page and
click triggers
add scheduler trigger
and I'm going to tell it when it should
run the job this is cron notation so I'm
going to ask you to run it at 2 am every
morning
click create
and just like that my job's now going to
run at 2 am every morning so it's really
easy to go from I have a cloud run job
to Let's schedule it to run regularly
as your jobs get more complex you'll
probably get to a point where you might
have multi-jet Parts jobs that you want
to chain
where each successive job uses the
output of the previous one
perhaps with some conditional logic in
between
Cloud workflows are a really good fit
for this
they're also great for error handling
because a cloud workflow will with the
jobs work close connector will run your
job wait for it to finish
see if it succeeded or failed and then
you can do further handling based on
whether it's succeeded or failed so this
is great for error handling kind of
outside the cloud run jobs retries
and you can even set up this workload a
workflow to run on a schedule so if you
want to run your cloud workflows
I don't know every every morning at 2
A.M you can set that up using Cloud
scheduler as well
Cloud run jobs can also be really useful
for background processing where a user
action results in some larger set of
operations that you want to do later
for example that deletion pipeline I
talked about imagine a user deletes
their data you don't want to kind of
block that operation you want to return
success to the user and then in the
background later you go through your
systems and all your deletion so Cloud
run jobs are a great place to offload
such processes to get them out of the
critical user interaction path
and here Cloud workflows can help again
so you wrap your job with a workflow
and then you set up event triggering for
your workflow
now you might think how do I get the
event payload into the cloud run job
and so I'm excited to announce that we
have added execution overrides to
clutter and jobs
and so thanks to this feature you can
parse out the event payload from the
event
and then have your workflow
pass that event payload to your job
either as an environment variable or as
arguments
so execution overrides lets you pass in
some information every time you actually
execute the job so they override
existing settings in the job without
changing the underlying configuration
you can overwrite environment variables
and arguments and this is useful to tell
the job for example this is where the
input is located this time
or perhaps you know to pass along that
event payload
you can also override the number of
tasks
and this is useful if your job is
written in a way that each task
processes exactly one piece of input so
you tell your job this time please run
12 instances because I have 12 pieces of
input
and lastly you can override the task
timeout this is useful when um so Cloud
run jobs only charge you when the job is
actually running but as we all know
sometimes we make mistakes and get
infinite Loops so it can be useful to
have a task timeout set kind of close to
how long you think the job ought to run
if there's no issue
and here's how you actually use cloud
run jobs with execution overrides so
we've got an execute button up there but
instead of clicking that we'll click the
little arrow
execute with overrides and now here I
tell it uh what my what new values I
want to set so I filled in here a new
value for the bucket environment
variable and so when I click execute
this job would run
so to sum this all up you want to use
cloud scheduler with Cloud run for
scheduled jobs
cloud workflows with Cloud run jobs for
complex workflow orchestration
and event Arc with cloud workflows and
Cloud run jobs for either event driven
jobs
or entire event driven data Pipelines
so finally let's talk about streaming
data process streaming data processing
streaming data processing is great
because it's conceptually simple an
event happens and you process it
um in general there are two major
paradigms when doing streaming data
processing we've got push-based and pull
based push-based is when your queue is
pushing events
to your compute endpoint
and pull based is when your compute is
actually workers that are running all
the time and pulling work from your
queue
so traditionally for serverless
pipelines people have used a push-based
model so what this looks like is you
tend to have a input source for example
cloud storage or Cloud logging
then you have a queue system that could
be a cloud Pub sub event Arc maybe Kafka
and then you have some sort of endpoint
serverless endpoint automatically scaled
like Cloud functions or Cloud run
that does the actual data processing and
then finally you write out the output to
some place like for example bigquery or
a database
and this works really well there are a
lot of customers using Cloud run and
Cloud functions for this type of use
case uh it's easy to set up
Cloud functions for example even has
built-in event Arc integration
and it automatically changed scales with
traffic and you don't pay anything when
you don't have any events
so you might ask should I use cloud
functions or Cloud run
and the answer in my opinion is again
use the simplest thing that works
so if you're processing code is really a
function
use cloud functions it's the easiest to
get started with you don't have to write
a Docker file so you don't have to
master build systems and it's got
built-in support for events
you might want to use cloud run on the
other hand if Cloud functions doesn't
support the language that you want to
use or if you want that container level
portability
or if you want control over the build
system for example for compliance
reasons
so now let's talk about pull-based data
processing
um
you want to use pull-based processing if
you have a really high throughput if you
have a really high volume of messages
and need to achieve High throughput
or if you need to achieve low latency
and the advantages of this kind of
Paradigm is that a twofold one is that
when you're doing push-based processing
you have really an HTTP request for
every piece of input data right so
that's overall less efficient
and so it's hard to get the same amount
of performance
and
um push-based processing also gives you
better control over smoothing out
traffic spikes
because in your streaming processing
pipeline if you're using a push-based
model if you have a huge amount of
events show up at a time your Q your
compute is going to scale way up
hopefully fast enough and then if you're
using a database for example as your
backing resource you might end up in a
situation where you have too many
workers trying to write to your database
with pull-based processing you can
control this by controlling the number
of instances a little more yourself
so uh that's let's let's bring this back
to how would you use this with Cloud run
again you have an input source you have
a cube at this time you have a pull
subscription to Pub sub
and you set up your Cloud run service
this time you want to use cloud run not
Cloud functions you set up your Cloud
run service with CPU always on
what this means
by default your Cloud run Services only
get CPU allocated when they're actually
processing requests
because this lets Cloud run give you
that great billing model where we only
charge you when your service is actually
processing a request
but when you're doing streaming data
processing when you when you have pull
based workers you don't have any
requests coming in so you want CPU all
the time so you set CPU to always
allocated and then you set your Min and
Max instances
now until recently I would have told you
you want to set Min and Max instances to
the same number
because Cloud run scaling was built
around request driven workloads and we
cannot scale this however
I'm happy to announce that in the coming
weeks we'll be rolling out a new feature
where I will Scale based on CPU
utilization
even when your service isn't processing
requests
so you'll be able to set Min instances
and Max instances to different values
and as long as your workload is CPU
bound
we'll be able to scale up your service
Up and Down based on the volume of
incoming messages
so that was a lot of content about
serverless products
but I wanted to make sure you got to see
an end-to-end example of how an actual
customer uses this for their system in
production to generate business insights
and so I spoke to Antoine custex from
L'Oreal unfortunately Antoine couldn't
be here today but he sent me this great
architecture diagram
so the team at L'Oreal loves bigquery so
one of the design goals
of over here was to get their data into
bigquery as quickly as possible as
efficiently as possible and then use SQL
and bigquery's advanced features to
generate insights and process it from
there
so starting on the left we see all the
data sources there's a lot of different
kinds of data here sales data product
data external data sources logs and so
forth and they're processing 150
petabytes per month these days
so the moment data arrives it triggers
either apogee or gets written to cloud
storage
and that generates a trigger that
triggers a cloud run service and that
cloud run service does two things first
it writes the data to bigquery that's
the whole we want to get it into
bigquery as quickly as possible step
and then it generates an event
that triggers a cloud workflow and that
cloud workflow takes the data through a
series of transformations
with various clutter and services
actually doing the compute work of
transforming the data and writing the
results into that shared bigquery data
set on the right
and then to actually use this data
they've defined a few separate bigquery
views so that different custom different
internal stakeholders can view the right
amount of data based on you know what
permissions they ought to have
and then finally
they've built several different ways to
actually consume that data for end users
end users being you know business
stakeholders inside the company so they
have a web front end built-in app engine
they also use looker as well as
third-party dashboards
so using all serverless components
L'Oreal was able to build an end-to-end
data warehouse pipeline
that's increased their efficiency and
lowered their maintenance costs
so putting it all together
um
in this talk we showed you how to build
serverless pipelines for data processing
you want to use cloud run jobs for
on-demand and batch processing
Cloud run services for streaming data
processing both push and pull based
and Cloud functions for event-driven
data processing
and this is all powered by our
constellation of orchestration products
and our great Suite of serverless data
storage products
so I hope you give this a try
on your next project
[Music]